[Musica]
che cos'è un armatura
a che cosa serve nel caso di august pole
man il protagonista di wonder e il suo
casco da astronauta pochi nascere una
malattia genetica rara la sindrome
editrice collins che colpisce
principalmente le fattezze del volto
lasciando inalterato e tutto il resto
o chi nasce quindi con il viso
malformato e subisce diversi interventi
chirurgici che gli servono per parlare
per mangiare per bere per respirare per
avere il più possibile un aspetto
normale bella storia dio di una storia
vera che si trova a vivere in prima
persona la scrittrice del libro e al
parco giochi con i suoi figli e mentre
si gode il tempo con loro
entra un'altra mamma con la sua bimba
affetta evidentemente dalla sindrome
editrice collins belle è improvvisamente
come punta da un'ape si alza di scatto
prende i suoi figli e corse corre verso
l'uscita del palco tutto questo perché
aveva paura paura che i suoi figli
potessero spaventarsi alla vista di
questa bambina
un po come era successo con i mostri di
halloween mentre si allontana sente però
l'altra mamma dire beh forse è meglio
che per oggi noi andiamo a casa con una
voce così carica di dolore così carica
di delusione da sentirsi un verme e da
scrivere questo splendido libro che
vuole essere un messaggio di scuse di
speranza e di uguaglianza
se però gi l'armatura il casco da
astronauta per me è il mio camicie il
mio camicie melo sono costruito ogni
singola volta che mi dicevano tu sei
troppo sensibile
tu sei troppo fragile troppo delicata
io ero sempre troppo qualcosa io sono
francesco andriani sono i geni st
dentale ma per i bimbi di cui mi prendo
cura
questo non è un armatura perché io per
loro sono semplicemente la francia
perché con loro mi sono tolta l'armatura
io sono la francia e questa è la mia
storia che non inizia 13 anni fa quando
per la prima volta mettevo piede
dalle sant'anna di como ma inizia molto
prima quando di anni ne avevo solo 6
eder in classe con andrea un bimbo come
hobby andrea era fisicamente diverso da
me eppure aveva una mamma e un papà come
me andrea mattei matite colorate aveva
quaderni aveva libri de andrè amava
giocare ma soprattutto andrea amava
amava e voleva essere amato e sorrideva
esattamente come me però molto spesso
andrea veniva escluso veniva allontanato
l'inter veniva lasciato solo gli altri
non volevano giocare con andrea
trattamento che a me non era riservato
io sono convinta che l'incontro con
andrea mi abbia cambiato la vita perché
non sarei la persona che sono oggi e non
avrei fatto le scelte che ho fatto se io
non avessi incontrato sono nata e
cresciuta in una famiglia dove mi sono
stati insegnati e trasmessi dei valori
molto importanti nel senso di famiglia
stesso l'amore il rispetto la dedizione
la dedizione al lavoro
l'aver cura l'apertura del prossimo ma
soprattutto mi hanno insegnato valori
come l'uguaglianza e la diversità perché
ce l'ha spiegato anche monica prima noi
sostanzialmente siamo tutti uguali tutti
diversi tutti unici e tutti originali
beh io forte di questi valori ho
iniziato il percorso che mi ha permesso
di diventare un igienista dentale e il
destino sulla mia strada ha messo un
altro andrea un'altra andrea è stato
pronto a cambiarmi la vita incontro
forse dovrei dire mi scontro a lezione
col dottor andrea di francesco lui per
me è stata la chiave perché se a 6 anni
avevo deciso che da grande avrei voluto
aiutare i bambini come andrea grazie a
lui ho potuto realizzare quel sogno
il dottor di francesca un chirurgo un
chirurgo maxillo facciale se da un punto
di vista puramente professionale ha
potuto insegnarmi poco da un punto di
vista umano mi ha insegnato tutto e mi
ha insegnato per dirla ligabue che
l'amore conta quando hai qualcuno di
così fragile vicino a te
quello che conta veramente è l'amore e
così entrò a far parte della sua equipe
della sua squadra è ben presto mi rendo
conto di che cosa voglia dire ancora di
un bambino fragile aver cura di un
bambino fragile vuol dire avere paura
paura di non essere all'altezza tremare
di paura di fronte alla tua impotenza
vuol dire sentirsi frustrati arrabbiato
perché non sai se riuscirai a fare
qualcosa di buono per per lui ma sai
soprattutto che non riuscirai a vincere
quella malattia rara sai che quella
patologia non la puoi sconfiggere vuol
dire studiare ogni giorno e più spesso
ogni notte vuol dire non avere orari
anche se non sei tu il medico
dell'ambulatorio poi deve essere pagati
poco o niente non avere garanzie
contrattuali
qualche volta vuol dire sentirsi
dilaniati perché quel bambino è
diventato un angelo e ha lasciato un
vuoto che sarà incolmabile ma aver cura
di quei bambini vuol dire principalmente
sentirsi amati a dismisura
a prescindere dal risultato vuol dire
ricevere dei sorrisi così pieni di gioia
e pieni di vita da sentirsi contagiati
sempre ogni giorno degli abbracci così
stretti che fanno toccare i vostri cuori
e tu quel cuore li lo metterai a nudo
perché avrei cura di lui e lui avrà cura
del tuo cuore
nello stesso identico modo significa
avere dalle loro famiglie così tanto
amore così tanta stima destro e
ricordati in ogni singola preghiera
affinché tu venga protetta aver cura di
un bambino fragile vuol dire
sostanzialmente diventare una
professionista ma soprattutto una
persona migliore che avrà sì paura di
tante cose ma mai della diversità aver
cura di un bambino fragile vuol dire che
quei bambini diventeranno i tuoi bambini
e tu lotterà con le unghie e con i denti
perché allora non venga negato più
nessun diritto
aver cura di un bambino fragile vuol
dire sentirsi sempre a maggio
vuol dire ricevere da quelle famiglie
così tanta dedizione così tanta fiducia
nel momento in cui ti affidano quello
che di più prezioso hanno molto spesso
mi viene chiesto
ma qual è la differenza tra prendersi
cura di un bambino fragile e di un
bambino che non è fragile la differenza
non esiste un bambino è un bambino
quando era in classe con andrea io non
lo sapevo ancora perché avevo solo sei
anni ma quella che mostravano i suoi
confronti era empatia
perché la verità è che quando andrea
piangeva quando andrea era triste io non
solo mi sentivo come lui vicino a lui io
diventavo andrea allo stesso modo la
differenza tra un bambino fragile non
fragile e solo negli occhi di chi guarda
perché un bambino e un bambino ea di
genitori esattamente come lo siamo noi a
per cura di un bambino fragile vuol dire
spesso essere a contatto e guardare
dritto in faccia il dolore la sofferenza
ed essere inermi non avere nessuna
possibilità di lenire quel dolore quella
sofferenza e poi un certo punto ti
accorgi che invece non è vero che tu con
un abbraccio con una carezza con una
mano tesa a quei genitori hai svoltato
la giornata è cambiato il punto di vista
perché loro non si sono sentiti più soli
abbandonati loro non si sono più sentiti
giudicati ma si sono sentiti
semplicemente accolti accolti da
qualcuno che vuole avere cura di loro e
per sentirsi così non è necessario
essere un medico io non sono un medico
su un igienista dentale non è neanche
necessario aver cura da un punto di
vista medico perché aver cura di una
persona fragile significa solo
proteggere la sua fragilità significa
solo proteggere il suo cuore e questo
nessuna intelligenza artificiale potrà
mai eguagliarlo perché il calore di un
abbraccio la forza di una mano tesa in
un momento di difficoltà non la puoi
eguagliare un sorriso contagioso non lo
puoi eguagliare
il sorriso di quei bambini e quello che
ogni giorno ti spingerà a dare il
massimo perché la verità è che in quel
momento quando tu vedrai gli occhi dei
loro genitori che dicono tutto senza
parlare a te non importerà per niente
dei soldi dai contratti della fatica non
team porterà più niente di avere paura
perché l'unica ricompense che desideri
sono quegli abbracci quei sorrisi pieni
di vita pieni di amore ea volte le
lacrime di gioia perché se c'è una cosa
che ho imparato da questi bimbi a non
arrendermi mai anche quando la vita ti
prende a calci anche quando ti vengono
sbattute porte in faccia a vedere la più
piccola possibilità come immensa se c'è
una cosa che io ho imparato da questi
bambini e la forza della fragilità
perché nella loro fragilità mostra una
forza che è contagiosa che è trainante
proviamo insieme per un attimo ad
immaginare il nostro figlio nostro
nipote un bambino che a noi sta
particolarmente a cuore che ha la
varicella
sentite il prurito sulla vostra pelle
guardatelo come soffre sofferenza che
per fortuna poi passa a per voi in quel
momento quella sofferenza insostenibile
e fareste qualsiasi cosa pur di
trasferire quel prurito sulla vostra
pelle pur di potervi grattare al posto
suo
i genitori di un bambino fragile si
sentono così ogni minuto di ogni singolo
giorno di ogni singola settimana di ogni
singolo mese ea volte si trovano a
desiderare qualcosa che per un genitore
inconcepibile e ora mentre guardate il
vostro bambino soffrire sentitevi soli
sentite il freddo il vuoto che vi
circonda
sentite che non c'è nessuno che a cura
della vostra fragilità nessuno che vi
guarda dritto in faccia e vi dice non ti
preoccupare io sono qui andrà bene
prendete la mano della persona che avete
di fianco prendetela in maniera delicata
ma decisa tornate in quel momento in cui
siete soli in cui siete al freddo al
buio e le persone vi passano di fianco e
si spostano con terrore vi guardano male
si spostano come se avessero paura
e si girano dall'altra parte nella
totale indifferenza
ora stringete quella mano le sentite
quanto vi arriva indietro
io sono qui sono qui per te ti proteggo
ti aiuto ti prendo per mano e sorrido e
ti porto fuori dalla tempesta
perché la verità è che noi per queste
famiglie ma per tutte le persone fragili
e non mi riferisco sulla bimbi affetti
da patologie genetiche rare dei bambini
disabili
tutti siamo stati siamo e saremo fragili
è nella nostra natura
ma quel gesto può fare la differenza
perché quel gesto può cambiare il corso
delle cose portano le aiutare da un
punto di vista medico
forse non gli e reader e the indietro il
caro che hanno perso forse non sarete in
grado di risolvere il problema di aver
perso il lavoro ma saprete comunque
dirgli io sono qua ti sostengo ti
proteggo e la verità è che noi possiamo
fare la differenza per queste persone
perché spesso quella mano tesa in quel
momento di bisogno rappresenta la
salvezza e la speranza la salvezza la
salvezza dall indifferenza dal
pregiudizio dalla paura di essere
giudicati dal non essere accettati dal
sentirsi soli
noi possiamo fare la differenza perché
noi siamo l'esempio dei nostri bambini
ei nostri nipoti dei bambini a cui
vogliamo bene
noi diamo loro l'esempio se noi
scappiamo di fronte a una famiglia con
un bambino disabile con un bambino
fragile il nostro figlio scapperà
terrorizzato il cuore di quella famiglia
si romperà ancora ancora e ancora
i bambini sono il nostro futuro
noi dobbiamo avere attenzione nei loro
confronti abbiamo il dovere di essere
per loro un vero esempio e di dargli un
mondo che è un pochino più attento un
pochino più gentile ed educato anche nei
confronti di chi è fragile
io sono la francia è questa in realtà
non è solo la mia storia è la storia di
tutti i miei bambini delle loro famiglie
del loro grande coraggio e sono sicura
che oggi questa diventerà la nostra
storia
perché sarà difficile ma per citare
ancora una volta ligabue nel nostro
piccolo possiamo fare qualcosa insieme
grazie
[Applauso]